38 في المائة من هؤلاء الأطفال
تخرج من الجامعات
38 في المائة من أطفالنا
أي كتاب بخلاف كتبك
لقد فتحوا فتحة باب الكارثة
يظهر هنا ثم نحن
لقد تغلبنا على الأبجدية اللاتينية الخاصة بك
إما هناك
[موسيقى]
و
معتبرين أن هذه الأبجدية لا تكفي
يبدو لماذا يكفي سببين
لا يكفي أولا مع هذه الأبجدية
معدل معرفة القراءة والكتابة لا يتحسن
لذلك الأفضل في كل حفرة في الإمبراطورية
حتى خلال هذه الفترة ، كانت أعلى من عشرة بالمائة.
معدل معرفة القراءة والكتابة لا شيء الأبجدية الثانية
لسوء الحظ ، أولئك الذين يعرفون هم أيضًا في الحروب.
قرأ وكتب عن موت الشباب
شرائح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أعتقد أن الأمر معقد للغاية بالنسبة للعثمانيين
كما كتب سطرين لهذه المدارس.
يمكن تعلم العثمانية كما لو كنا نصغي
هل هو صعب للغاية الآن
الآن يمكن أن يقال
هل هذا محمد ام محمود ام هو حب؟
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في عام 5928 ، بدأ أتاتورك إصلاح الأبجدية.
عندما يفعل فهذا يعني في فكره
وفقًا لهذا ، في عام 1938 ، كانت أمتنا بأكملها دونية.
95 من أصل 100 معرفة القراءة والكتابة في المجموعة
سيكون من الجميل من خلال إصلاح الأبجدية
لقد مرت 10 سنوات وما زال عدد سكاننا مرتفعًا
معظمهم لا يستطيع القراءة أو الكتابة.
عدة لمن يستطيع القراءة والكتابة
هذه المعلومة غير موجودة هل تعلم؟
95 من أصل 100 من منازلنا خالية من الكتب و
إنها مكتبة ، لم يحدث شيء من هذا القبيل
ميل
[موسيقى]